you
there we go French defense I wanted to
see the French defense but what about
that move right what about that move
what was it d5 when both of my pawns
could have captured it man
all right this is this is strictly play
against computer when I do this stuff
got rid of their number one Bishop I
think it gives me a very good
opportunity to win here we go now we're
looking for a queen trade now I could
take and I'm going to hey let's get
developed if Bishop here then I take out
the knight all right let's do this
Bishop takes I don't do this what I like
forks
it's just Castle well my queen on d5
hmm maybe if this pawn has gone far
enough and I do this
although Queen b3 is quite annoying I'll
do this anyway I think I could
conveniently defend here now I think
Queen d8 defend my bishop allowing my
knight to take here finally let's go
with that I don't think I'm missing
anything tactically one slip and that's
all it's gonna take
now that's surprising huh gave up the
bishop huh what's its idea Knight here
maybe yeah here comes pressure against
this structure but it's not always it
doesn't always correctly assess the
sacrifices against like them
it'll go in for rook and two pawns it'll
it'll take a rook in two of your pawns
and give up two minor pieces and that's
not always the right thing to do it
gives too much weight to the material
and then it kind of doesn't have a
constructive plan thereafter now I could
play this check I could also kick the
knight
if I kick the knight right now it's
probably gonna sacrifice no I don't
think so I don't think it's in a
position to do that
so I think just h6 my Knights there to
defend and what what might follow up is
something like Knight g4 I'd be okay
with g6 though let's think for a second
though let's consider Queen check you
know what Queen check f3 I could see it
doing and then if I kick the night it'll
go here and then I'm never really in a
position to capture I'd like to be able
to trade pair of Knights if the knight
goes here and not have to two white
pawns in the center like that I think h6
am I missing anything
all right let's go let's see if there's
a tactic I don't think there is oh my
goodness there is okay it's really going
for this this is not correct though it's
definitely not correct I know it's not I
just know it's not correct I could do
this oh maybe I should have done that
move first I could kick him out of there
though
get out of my house get out of my house
okay and that'll Queen here I see I have
everything covered and I'm just doing
this so I could play Queen rook here and
defend I have this covered yeah I
figured I figured you would do that
you're real good you're really good at
consolidating Queen check yep nice
anticipation here's my plan
Queen train now how do I move forward
how do I move forward isn't is the big
question hmm
what to do I don't want to move my
structure I I don't I think I should
just sit and wait there how will you
cope with the sit and wait plan uh-huh
yeah okay so there you go you're looking
to play here aren't you what about g6 I
don't have a great home for my King
anymore but I don't I think his home
from now on is f7 so my king is going to
have to simply deal with it deal with it
f7 is your home and that no soup for you
right there with g4 now I could play
Queen here and I think I could get the
Queen's off the board
cuz I'm threatening this pawn it's
beautiful I want the Queen's off the
board
actually Queen here there's queen bee
three sneakiness everywhere that's
uncomfortable to defend this pawn and
then I could play b6 but then queen c4
or just king g2 so I don't think that
would um work out so well maybe I could
do this though and now I'm threatening
this cuz there's a he's protected
indirectly ah this is a beautiful move
to see Knight here here here get him to
f5 maybe Bishop here first I'm getting
excited here can you sense it I have
control over this position let's trade
you want to trade take my queen you
didn't take my queen take the queen and
we could share the championship together
name that quote name that movie where
trick or treat Trick or Treat time is
that we have 30-second warning alright
let's let's see what it does here
you got nothing you've got nothing
ah it's offering a drop I'll take that
as a victory but I want more yes there
you go weak in that position it's true
my knight in there how comfortable is it
now how comfortable is it now when
you're flushed from this file there we
go now my route could do some other
exciting things uh-huh oh I missed that
move don't you dare take that rook
unless you like pins
I'm not afraid though should I be get
out of there
rook oh I still can't take but it
weakened another square I'm gonna move
my king where to though
a lot of time rook here oh no I don't
want to do that
I should have control over this position
though I have to give up my queen
maybe my rook I want my rook back here
yes okay okay hang on
okay I'm gonna do this my knight wants
to be on d5 okay get him there get my
rook here I still want a queen trade I
clean up defending his chief for stuff
defend um back up rope here here bishop
here to here Queen you know what it's
gonna do it's gonna take my queen when I
play here if I play here let's not do
that just yet it's wait I need to I need
to gain some time here
oh it just dropped upon oh man oh I
didn't want to do that I shouldn't have
done that let's come back ah my bishop
needs to stay there now they're gonna
inch their pawn up Oh mmm not cool
I'm floundering right now hello boy I
passed pawn town oh boy oh boy
let's check maybe has to go for
perpetual now oh my goodness it's
allowing that of course it is of course
it is there mustn't be a good discovery
and how it wants a queen trade of course
you do I don't think I could allow it at
this point though you insist though you
definitely insist and I'm down on time
oh if I didn't give up the e5 pot I need
to keep my Bishop on c7 and just play my
queen of g4 cuz it would have taken cuz
its it values those double isolated
pawns is a very good thing for itself
you